over the weekend during a historic
speech as I mentioned the president did
champion what is rightly called American
exceptionalism and American greatness
let's take a look well this wonderful
day we celebrate our history our heroes
our heritage a great American flag and
our freedom the American Republic stands
today is the greatest most exceptional
and most virtuous nation in the history
of the world we are the descendants of
the most daring and courageous people
ever to walk on the face of the earth by
the way and the president announced
National Garden of Heroes with Americans
from every race every background all
Americans celebrated for their greatness
and their exceptionalism to think is a
great idea the ever frail the ever
confused they have a corrupt Joe Biden
celebrating the fourth of July in a
different way and what was a highly
produced what 97 second video Biden
bashing the u.s. saying this country
never lived up to the idea that all are
created equal he now wants to transform
our country he said perhaps Biden
doesn't comprehend any of this because
no country no people are perfect that's
just a fact that's a basic fundamental
truth an undeniable truth thanks to the
wisdom of our framers and fathers though
they developed this great constitutional
republic a system that allows this
country the right to correct wrongs and
correct in justices and always strive
and move towards improvement so we can
become that more perfect union and by
the way as the president said both in
his Friday night and Saturday night
addresses this is the beauty of America
that is what we celebrate and of course
no we're not perfect but we have the
ability we have the willpower to become
that more perfect union we've made major
major progress we need to make much more
major progress to fulfill that dream of
a more perfect union for example you can
look at for existing back in history
seventeen hundred's dozens and dozens of
our framers at our Constitutional
Convention unsuccessfully arguing
against the evil practice of slavery for
example dr. Benjamin Franklin calling it
a quote atrocious to basement of human
nature of course he's a thousand percent
correct as is James Madison calling it
dishonorable to the national character
he was right George Mason calling
slave-owners petty tyrants ultimately
hundreds of thousands of Americans
fought and died over this very issue
that is our history Emancipation
Proclamation is also our history later
the Voting Rights Act the Civil Rights
Act ensured through federal law and
constitutional amendments do we have
further to go absolutely and by the way
what did Biden and other Democrats
what'd they want you to forget as many
of those that they so admire and call
their mentor well they fought tooth and
nail against these important reforms for
example it was a Democrat George Wallace
who stood in the doorway of that
Birmingham school to physically block
racial integration it was a Democrat
Bull Connor who used fire hoses and
police dogs to attack civil rights
peaceful protesters it was over a
hundred Democratic lawmakers voted
against the 64 Civil Rights bill Al
Gore's father a prominent Democratic
senator well he actually filibustered
the bill so did Robert KKK Byrd the
former Klansmen so did noted
segregationist J William Fulbright all
Democrats keep in mind Bill Clinton
called Fulbright his mentor he eulogized
Fulbright while he was serving as
president and despite his past as a Klan
leader and actually the head of the Klan
modern Democrats practically lined up to
shower Robert Byrd with praise they even
made him the Senate Majority Leader
Hillary Clinton calling Robert Byrd the
heart and soul of the US Senate Chuck
Schumer calling Byrd one of the greatest
men in history Pelosi calling Byrd an
American patriot biting Colin bird the
Dean of the US Senate a close friend and
a mentor of mine
imagine if Donald Trump said this about
a forum about a Klansmen now keep in
mind Biden once worked side by side with
segregationist
this is Joe Biden's record in a speech
in 1973 then-senator Biden praising
Southern Democrats and said that the
two-party system in the South was quote
good for the bleep and around the same
time Biden was actively working working
with these segregationist he was slowing
and trying to stop integration opposing
school busing and according to NBC News
quote he led the charge that on an issue
that kept black students away from the
classrooms from white students that's
Joe Biden that's the Democratic nominee
that's his history those who questions
the mob have not asked him in 1977 Biden
worried that his children would grow up
quote in a racial jungle if integration
is not done in his orderly way whatever
that means
1993 referring to inner-city youth as
quote predators on our streets as he
co-authored an aggressive crime bill
ramping up prison sentences for dozens
of crimes and of course Biden's racist
rhetoric didn't stop him in the 90s
remember in 2006 he told the crowd well
you have to have a slight Indian accent
to work at a 7-eleven or a Dunkin Donuts
and I'm not joking also in 2006 bragging
his state was a slave state who would
brag about that in 2007 called Barack
Obama eventually came vice president
quote the first mainstream African
American who's actually articulate and
bright and clean wow that story book man
what and last year he said quote poor
kids could be just as bright as white
kids and a few weeks ago he told the
radio host Charlemagne the God that you
ain't black unless you support him over
Trump excuse me this is the guy that
says he wants to transform America what
into that because after decades of all
of his BS and 125 years of combined
failure of Biden Pelosi and Schumer that
should be in charge if God forbid you
elect them in 120 days
Trump is done more in 3.5 years as I
mentioned that they could even ever
think of truth matters hypocrisy matters
for all you intellectually lazy people
in the mob
won't ask these questions won't inform
your viewers of this history you are
failing and derelict in your duty
actions matter decade after decade after
decade after decade five decades Biden
he had ample opportunity to make America
a more perfect union instead he made one
weird racial statement after another
some you know one comment about
integration segregation and by the way
did nothing to end violence in American
cities and by the way imagine if Donald
Trump had said any of these things have
supported any of these people that these
modern Democrats supported guess what
history matters truth matters their
failed record matters and it's on the
ballot in 120 days